who let Kev show bootleg have podcast
special guests in here Ben Reilly
representing Brooklyn and Atlanta at the
same time yeah Brooklyn
not your hero for hires the latest EP
that's out yes sir
um do you have uh I I think we just came
up with the name of your next project
Brook Lana nah
so the uh the project I'm working on is
called uh save that's the album
um natural for hires like a Prelude to
it okay it's just ideas that I feel
didn't uh fit the narrative how long you
been rapping uh I'm 27 I've been rapping
since I was like 13 14. oh so yeah
you're [__] you ain't you ain't new
to this you're True to this man for sure
how long like before like you really got
some traction before like you know you
were like oh I might have a a chance
here so like locally in Atlanta I was
getting traction like 2015 2016 17 that
time
um it wasn't until like 2021 when I
dropped my first like solo project
because I've been in a group for a while
um so what group are you in uh it's
called abstract media okay
um but uh it wasn't until 2021 where I
dropped my like first solo project and
um locally like [__] was just like yo
this [__] is crazy and then the next
year it went viral and then I was able
to like quit my day job and [__] and
that's always that should be a good
feeling when you say here's my two weeks
did you even give them two weeks uh yeah
yeah
hey look respectfully I'm [__] up out
of here yeah no yeah that missing toilet
paper that was me too [__] you take it
out of my check no uh I had a really
good standing with uh the people I was
working what was your last real job I
was bartending at a burger joint oh nice
yeah yeah yeah so I was doing all right
Smash Burgers nah so uh so it's this
burger joint called Bad Daddy's that
sounds fire the burgers are good you
know once you worked there for a while
you kind of like you get over it yeah
it's like if you get it's like anywhere
I feel like if you work at a Food Spot
you're gonna get tired of the food
because you eat it all the time facts
1000 so you're a hell of a bartender you
can say that I'm not like great at it
where like [__] be like
flipping but you can make a drink you
know what's in every drink yeah like if
I was like uh give me a uh what's the
thing in the metal cup I like
with the ginger beer Moscow meal Moscow
meal easy that's my favorite drink I
don't even know the [__] name of it
Moscow meal you got Irish mules uh got
Kentucky mules stuff like that yeah all
right well listen man uh the ep's out
when's your album coming out uh we're
still working it out we're still working
it is it done no it's not done yet yeah
so I'm still working out the Kinks for
it so nice but I'm I'm like a good like
60 70. yeah I feel like when you're
you're probably at the at the spot where
you're like you don't know if all the
songs are finished they're sample
clearance [__] maybe you're waiting on a
feature or two yeah it's stuff like that
it's still kind of working to see if you
catch something that fits on the album
literally that literally so
um I got all the like super personal
like
you got the main ones where you're like
this is on the album yeah yeah I got all
that [__] yeah yeah 100 man look we're
gonna have you do your thing uh any
anything else people should check out or
or that uh yeah not your hero for hire
the EP out now uh freelance and
freelance Charlie out now uh yeah let's
get right to it man Ben Reilly I Like
Rappers too it's not my government
though that's a random rap game yeah
extra extra I know you heard a lot about
them I pieced together words that'll
make it hard to die don't collected a
hundred thousand paid everyone around
them my pockets carry around more
singles than an album evil man about to
tell a story about what he began to even
is that I put in and left me with
experience my dog had a machine on them
hoping he could eat again tinkering with
bells fairly well we call them Peter Pan
my pheromones giving red smells tell her
farewell baby I'm rocking pale pale in a
stairwell baby still well before I step
to you and raise your be 2015 we will
scalping future tickets like it's here
Joe baby you should read the room you
know the fun sway off I'm taking no days
off them long ones gonna pay off I'm
acting like Bernie telling me like made
of you cannot see my stash you should
ate or Flash yourself ask yourself am I
the reason you match yourself all
because you know you ain't up for the
tax yourself great in the Gatsby need a
Janet a vastly Kiki to harass me big man
if you nasty actually I'll be happy be
stacking sheets don't get at me I'm
packing heat this is Vanity half a
reason this season back is giving Peter
13 Reasons be for me you got a better
chance that diamond gonna feed it okay
part of me but I ought to be way more
disrespectful it's hard to find a harder
beat for y'all [__] to step to rap two
throw up your set too and impress you
she only gonna caress you if it ain't
hard to finesse you but me and my dogs
aiming for Force what you in it for
Randy alone with a 40 drone bet your
menopause period shorty got me bent like
a figure four serious what the [__] she
worried about my figures for and ain't
no twisting my arms I ain't with the arm
wrestling been working bars so long I
could perform Tetris I'm off the next
exit no need to duck my exes I'm good
with all along [__] it I'm ambidextrous
and not for nothing this for all of you
folks I got a 4x4 riding four four with
my foes I sound like hope maybe I should
keep with the foes maybe not well I
pulled out her front oh God bless you on
my pillow got hits they gon hit em I
paint the walls road runners
down she think I'm scamming ass like two
planets that might do damage [__] that I
managed okay
but we from we just peace up we done
okay hop out like a bounce house gonna
leap out I'm done two tone like a leave
out throw the scheme out I'm done yeah
Jesus Christ wow natural hero fire then
rally
that's it I think I said ain't nothing
else to say man my God that was amazing
thank you thank you brother I appreciate
you guys watching this freestyle we got
another one coming and then another one
and then another one and they're all
brought to you by our good Folks at LRG
clothing you already know what it is LRG
been keeping you fly for years they got
so much new fly gear right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30 off
l-r-g.com another freestyle is on the
way presented by LRG